here now with more and what is a story
hopefully we can learn things from is
the Florida Governor Ron de Santos one I
let you make your case and welcome put
we'll put these these slides back on the
screen I'm gonna be honest governor I
was particularly worried about the state
of Florida I've been to the villages III
have a a place in South Florida and been
down there a lot old people down there
that's where they retire you have a very
high elderly population how did you do
this because I would think Florida would
have been one of the worst-hit states
well you're right Shawn people were
predicting us to be worse than New York
like another Italy they said that that
this week one of the newspapers in
Florida said we'd have four hundred and
sixty four thousand people hospitalized
the actual numbers twenty two hundred so
we beat that by four hundred and sixty
two thousand but what we did very early
was focus on the populations who were
most at risk as you mentioned are senior
citizens and particularly our nursing
homes and assisted living facilities we
instituted screening for all staff
immediately we stopped visitation we
required all staff to wear n95 mass I
charge the National Guard with doing
strike teams to do spot testing at the
facilities to try to figure out if any
of the staff are asymptomatic whenever
there was an incident at a nursing home
we send these Quick Response Teams to go
and try to limit the infections and so
we focused on a laser we've put out
Shawn almost six million masks just to
our nursing homes and assisted living
facilities and so we understood the risk
that this post had the senior population
we worked with the villages
constructively on social distancing and
here's the thing you don't have to be
draconian at the villages they're
playing golf just like they always do
but they're doing it with social
distancing so they don't share a car
with anyone they don't touch the
flagstick and they've ended up doing
very well the president tweeted
congratulations to them so I think it's
been a team effort here in Florida we
got a great public health people at the
county level
we've worked we're very good with state
or state or the local governments as
well we still got more work
to do but clearly we've done way better
than all the experts said we would and I
think we did it by a smart data-driven
approach and by the way the villages
I've been there that is America's
friendliest hometown they do a lot of
drinking they go to a lot of concerts
they watch movies the dinner they play
golf tennis pickleball thing whatever
you call that sport that I don't even
know anything about and thankfully but
you it seems like you went right at the
most vulnerable population and that's
where you put your biggest efforts and
it's paid off one other thing that I
noticed that you are saying and and I
hope maybe we can learn something from
this is that you're telling people go
outside and get some Sun don't hide in
your house that was interesting to me
and you did open up beaches right I lay
out but to walk on where exactly and so
you know people would play golf with
social distancing they would fish go on
on boat now they're on having big
parties they are maintaining social
distance but I think that that's healthy
and to just sit inside for two months
eating Cheetos and stuff and watching
Netflix that's not great so so I think
we respected people I think they did it
the right way and I think it's paid off
these draconian orders I don't think
have worked throughout the country I
think I we got to look at every place
where it worked and I thought your state
was the most vulnerable these numbers
are amazing
great work thanks for saving America's
elderly these these are the greatest
generation and in between and amazing
people and keep up the good work of Anor
keep us updated on that